kelly après midi cuisine pour ces mères
de famille de magny les hameaux
au menu saumon aux petits légumes un
plat spécialement adapté pour lui tout
petit
l'atelier organisé par le centre social
de la ville et en partenariat avec le
secours catholique s'adresse aux
familles qui peuvent avoir des
difficultés
on s'est dit pourquoi pas faire cet
accompagnement pour leur montrer comment
faire de la cuisine simple qui coûte
finalement moins cher que ce qu'on peut
trouver comme que la préparer et qui est
beaucoup plus saine carottes navets
persil mais aussi banane pour le goûter
tous les produits sont de saison faut
éviter de manger les fruits les légumes
hors saison parce que ça coûte plus cher
et vient de loin certes au et ya pas
beaucoup de buts amis comment on peut
imaginer les recettes ont été élaborés
avec l'aide d'un pédiatre pour que les
besoins nutritionnels des enfants en bas
âge soient respectés cette première fois
j'ai réussi j'ai trouvé les bières et
bien du très banal et la firme a lancé
le premier c'est magnifique
le goûter et de l'emprunt si leur ait
pas de soirées parc avec chaque mois les
jeunes parents repartent chez eux avec
des recettes différentes c'est
d'ateliers cuisine ont également un
autre objectif amener du lien social
entre les différentes familles